普通にするとこれです
ちょっと、さすがにきもすぎる
分け目をつけると、まあかろうじてキモいです
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
前髪切りすぎてテンションが低いです
あの、片頭痛
なぜか今日は片頭痛がひどいので
今日はシュって感じです
昔ですね僕、サーキュレーターを沢山買って
それで紙飛行機を永遠に飛ばそうっていうことを考えてたんですけども
まあ余裕のよっちゃんで無理でした
なんですけども
あの後、僕色々調べたり
皆さんの情報をいただいて色々調べたんですけども
ネットで
サーキュレーターを2つ使えば
紙飛行機が永遠に浮いてるみたいな
今日それを実際にやってみようと思います
実家のまさきとか皆にあげちゃったので、だいぶ数は減ったんですけど
2つあればできるって聞いた
ホントにできたら、ホントに嬉しいんですけど
ちょっと怖いな
やり方としては
サーキュレーター2つをこう向かい合わせます
で、向かい合わせて多分同じくらいの強さにするのかな
同じくらいの強さにして
このちょうど中間に紙飛行機を置くとなんかこうね
ずっと浮いてたみたいな
これ見てわかると思うんですけど
スパイラル状になってるわけですよスパイラル
螺旋状になってるんで
この回転力を上手いこと何か利用したら
紙飛行機がずっとここでキープされるのかなって思います
まあ、これがうまくいけば紙飛行機を永遠に浮かせるということが可能になるので
今日は実際にやってみようと思います
あの、話変わるんですけど最近ポケモンGOにはまってて
頑張って、レベル19まできました
ありがとうございます
ビードルだ
紙！
ひとまず、紙飛行機を作りましょう
前髪なくてキモいよー
やあ、これさぁ、でもさぁ
わかんないんだよね
ネットの情報だったので
信憑性に欠けてます
ひょっとしたら誰かがたまたま、合成でやっちゃっただけみたいな
そういう可能性もあるので
これが本当に正しいかどうかはやってみないとわかんないっす
というわけで完成しました、紙飛行機でございます
まずは中くらいでいい気が思います
上手く螺旋の中心を捉えろ
完璧な螺旋の中心を
これで本当にできるのかな
いきます
なんか、絶対無理な気がしてきた
こんなの無理だよ、だって
絶対
いや、これ、ちょっと待って
本当に無理じゃない？
ネットのやつもこれでなってたのに
強でやります
もう絶対無理でしょ
あ～もう
しっかり合わせることから始めなきゃいけない気がする
あ～～
あ、あ、待って今なんか、今なんか感じたよ
待って、なんか感じる
そうでもねぇや
なんか惜しい気はするんだけどなー
もう怒った
結局辿り着くのはこれなんですよね
これも全然すごいんですけども
浮かせられないのかな
これを上手いこと使ってる気がするんですよね
わかんないですけど
だって純粋にこれ紙飛行機がずっと回ってるわけなので
これをなんかどうにかしたらできるのかな？っていう
でも、これちなみに風の強さ強めると動いちゃうんですよ
やっぱこれ弱い風専用の必殺技みたいな感じがします
楽しい
もうこれあっぷるぅｌ
中にすると強すぎて浮いちゃうんですよ
なので
この中で浮いちゃう状態に
上からこれをこう被せて
こっちを弱にします
そして上手いこと
無理かもー
いや、何事も挑戦です、やってみましょう
ないな、これはない
紙飛行機の形的に無理じゃない？
多分無理だよこれ無理無理無理
待って、やばいやばい浮いてる浮いてる浮いてる！
浮いてる！完全に浮いてる
完全に浮いてる完全に！やばい
すごいすごい
すいませんでしたー！
9月12日（月）天気
東京　曇時々雨　降水確率90%
大阪　曇時々雨　降水確率50%
静岡　曇時々雨　降水確率80%
広島　曇りのち一時雨　降水確率80%
福岡　雨　降水確率100%
京都　曇時々雨　降水確率60%
やばい！やばい！浮いてる浮いてる！
やばいやばい！浮いてる浮いてる！
やばいやばいやばい浮いてる！
はははｗ